in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
joining me in the studio today is dr.
Pike indica a preventive dentistry
expert at Berlin's Charity Hospital
hello and welcome to in good shape when
you look at the report the root canal
work looked very very complicated does
the tooth actually survive the procedure
the tooth itself survives the procedure
yes is it Rickman's retained in the
mouth but the root canal system is
usually filled by a nerve and blood fuel
tissue and that is removed so the tooth
itself is there but it's dead it's empty
inside and filled with an artificial
material okay so but but but but if the
tooth is dead why doesn't it fall out
because the tissue rounded the
periodontium as we say it's a fibrous
and bone which retained the tooth that's
still intact that still works and that's
why the tooth remains there so it's just
the cover of the tooth and there are no
nerves in it there's no blood vessels in
it so do you have any feelings any
sensations inside the tooth and the
perfect situation you shouldn't know
because all the tissue which can
transport feelings the nerve tissue is
removed so you shouldn't feel anything
no pain and you wouldn't also feel
carriers or these kind of things - not
at all no and which is good on one hand
because you don't have any toothache
then and you don't have to go and see
your doctor because it's painful but on
the other hand there's no warning sign
exactly that's absolutely true there's
no warning sign well that's the general
problem with carriers the most carious
lesions don't hurt that's why patients
often notice them very late and that's
when they come and usually we can't do
that much in most cases any longer so
what I would suggest is go regularly see
the dentist he takes an x-ray every one
or two years depending on your interval
and then you can be controlled for
carriers but also for infection
inflammation in that too but on the
other hand when a tooth which you
repaired with the root canal surgery and
if it gets painful what does that this
suggests it can suggest several things
but if you look at these this root canal
treatment we saw it it's very difficult
it's a very complex system which we have
to shape to clean to remove all the
bacteria from and that does not always
work perfectly so in some cases bacteria
remain and that can cause inflammation
that can cause infection that can also
cause pain and that's I would say the
most frequent reason why such a root
canal treatment doesn't work perfectly
advice is so difficult to clean out
every canal because
it's a biological thing such a tooth and
it's not perfectly standardized so it
has a certain amount of canals which we
don't know in advance the knesset
irregularly-shaped we are basically
working in the blind and the dark
some of us work with a microscope or
anything but nevertheless it's difficult
to see and to feel all the canal and
perfectly clean and shape but that's why
we can't reach all the areas and
sometimes that's a problem because of
the remaining bacteria so if it's so
difficult I mean it's difficult for the
patient as well because it's a painful
and long procedure and it's difficult
for the dentist so why do you even
bother to repair the root canal and
clean it out by them to just pull the
tooth I think there are two reasons for
that the one is that technically we have
the option to retain the tooth to do a
root canal treatment with good success
rates and also dentists these days have
these abilities and on the other hand
and I think it's even more important
quite a patients demand that from us I
think our our feeling what we want what
kind of teeth we want to retain it has
changed over the time and patients want
to retain their own teeth they see this
as part of the whole mouth and a very
holistic and biologic approach and so
patients and tenders together often want
to retain and keep the tooth for ages
dangerous where the solutions for teeth
loss and nowadays there are implants but
what disadvantage do implants have I
think they have two disadvantages we
can't use them in all situations so for
example for medically compromised
patients patients which have some kind
of problems with bleeding or also
patients with for example a radio after
irradiation and these patients they have
difficulties getting them and also the
bone amount where we place the implant
in needs to be there so there are some
situations where it's not possible to
place implants and on the other hand
implants are more expensive than normal
dentures that's why also the financial
situation is often something which
speaks against an implant so what do you
mean by a bone amount which needs to be
there is it if there's not so much bone
around you can just plug it in exactly
because the implant as we saw needs a
certain amount of bone to rest in and to
be stabilized by and if that bone is not
there we have a problem because we can't
stabilize that you can rebuild that so
there are surgical techniques to rebuild
and gain bone but only to a limited
degree so in some situations it's not
possible
Flintstone so if you put an implant
successfully in how long does it usually
last
that depends for I think several decades
we thought okay the implant might even
be the better - that can last for very
very long but we've learned that
especially biological complications are
a problem their implants can get a
similar disease like periodontitis or
like tooth they can get an information
around the implant itself and the
tissues in the soft tissue and the bone
and that inflammation is not that easy
to cure and probably limits in some
patients the durability of such an
implant is there some special care
patient has to take care of you to get
the implants last forever as I said for
teeth you have the risk of periodontitis
and hereõs okay an implant can't get
caries so that's already soft but for
periodontitis you would try to clean as
much as possible you would use flossing
or interdental brushes and that's
something especially those brushes they
might be slightly different but you
would use them for implants as well and
your dentist or the dental hygienist put
exactly tell you how to clean an implant
yes and this is the thing with the
implants the same like with gum disease
in normal teeth it's very similar
we know that the biologics behind it is
slightly different and especially the
therapy is very different because the
implant is a rough structure that's how
it's retaining the bone so it's very
difficult to clean by the dentist and
that's why we have the problem with that
peri-implantitis is usually goes quicker
and deeper than in normal periodontitis
but in basic yes it's similar okay we've
got a lot of viewer questions I just ask
you some and jackée's think of it from
the US wants to know about oil swishing
could you just explain what what all
swishing isn't it is useful and the idea
behind it is that you basically swish
this world with the oil in your mouth
and you you place it on all the tooth
surfaces so the bacteria can't adhere or
too good fatty film and it's a nice idea
but it hasn't been proven to really work
so I personally I would rather spend my
time instead of swirling and swishing
with the oil by brushing my teeth are
using floss all that kind of stuff okay
and or I run from the US ask several
questions one of this was and when will
we be able to print our own teeth in a
3d printer that's an interesting
question I think we are already quite
far into that process when it comes to
dentures and crowns so it's nearly a
standard technique the digitally
designing crowns and printing them it's
not
reprinting it's milling but it's similar
for her teeth I think it will be still a
while from now because teeth are very
very complex they are very complex
structures so I think we are still some
time away from printing her teeth
another question aura asked us was that
she has F ceramic fillings that fall out
every few years and does you have any
alternatives to their sandwich fillings
I think if you play such filling
ceramics or composite fillings they
usually glued into the tooth and that
should work and so there might be a
reason why this doesn't work it might be
the gluing process for example but
basically there are alternatives but I
would rather try to reglue it in a
proper way so and it sees their dentist
except dr. Shannon can thank you so much
for being with us today in the studio
thanks and goodbye
you